foreign
[Applause]
's complete if they spend it wrapped in
dirty sheets yes those bums don't dread
spend it all day in bed we're talking
about those born after 1997 when cat
just turned 20.
well they're taking time out of their
busy jam-packed work-filled schedules to
stay in bed all day long doing crap
other than sleep or have sex they got
the idea from Brian kilmeade's new book
my sad empty life damn
I don't know why but it's a trend called
bed rotting what I feel like this is not
real and it's popular on Tick Tock like
everything awful
and it's also a big hit with doordash
Uber Eats and of course bed bugs these
young people look at Bed rotting as
necessary mental self-care a logical
Next Step from a generation that peaked
with eating Tide Pods they're recharging
their minds by binge watching movies and
TV shows stuffing their faces with
sugary and fattening snacks all in bed
where's bright stelter calls it business
as usual
[Laughter]
one tick-tocker even said quote I feel
my purpose in this life is to rot in
different places my bed Hotel bed beach
sand hammock I was made to lay and rot
back in my day you couldn't simply
decide to spend your whole life in bed
you had to earn that by getting polio
real bedroding Fanatics call it a hobby
and a passion which has us asking is it
too early to harvest their organs
Cyrus do you think this is real that
quote was almost two on the nose too
perfect I feel like you know the movie
Princess Bride I don't think they think
rot means what they think it means it's
not a good term like no one ever wants
to tell anyone they have something
that's rotten yeah or rot and someone be
like oh I want that
they don't this is uh obviously the
uncles came home so people are sitting
on the couch yeah Mom and Dad are taking
over the living room again good for Mom
and Dad they're countering and they came
back with final just rot in my bed and
they'll sit there and do what they're
pretty much doing already sitting on
their phones watching Netflix and now
they just get to lay down and do it yeah
like this is again this is what they do
whenever adversity hits they just change
the name instead of being a lazy ass or
a couch potato or in my whole house
leaving soon at the end of my foot uh
they're now bedroting and it's for my
mental health so you can't tell me that
I'm lazy and not doing with my life
I don't know you know uh Tom I I feel
like I did this for a while it was
called College yeah I just lie I one
time I think I aimed a lie in bed for a
whole week right I did I I used to throw
the dishes under the bed you had dishes
in college yes we didn't have any any
dishes but yeah you know dishes yeah
well there I mean they were plastic but
dishes nonetheless I'm against bed Greg
oh really yeah well I don't like
spending any time in the bed no TV in
the bedroom I don't want to be lingering
in the bedroom I just sleep yeah and I
love sleeping but I sleep I get my nine
hours and then I get out of there nine
hours I like I like nine I need nine
I need nine hours and it's nine from
beginning to end no interruptions no
interruptions in college to be more
productive I got rid of my bed so I
didn't have a bed for three years
would you sleep on hammock hi I slept in
a hammock okay where it really is yeah I
slept in a hammock they called me cocoon
boy oh they did
it was an excellent hammocks are a great
great way to sleep because you get in
you fall asleep you wake up you have to
get out of it I mean you can't linger
but then two people can't be in it ah
come on I was in college
that means you were alone
look I know they do these days but this
was the 1980s there was no sex in
college
Emily what are your thoughts on a not
having sex in college or B this topic
which makes no sense I'll take B okay I
find all of them disgusting it's like
they're filming and celebrating getting
bed sores everyone is lazy and filthy
and I'm sick of it and also given that
all of us in New York are sort of like
crammed together in subways and walking
and everything you can smell when
someone spends too much time in bed
right smell it on their hair and on
their clothes and I just find this one
more reason why this generation should
be
you fill in the blank no I'm just
kidding but I feel like that they're
that they're you know they're lazy and
weird and to your point they're just
doing it again for the clicks and the
dopamine like that that point I was made
to rot in a hammock okay honey get a job
yeah you know uh we already had cat we
already have one movement uh defending
the one of the original sins of gluttony
right it's called Uh body positive why
don't we have energy positive people
some people don't have the energy you do
you know so they have to like some
people need nine hours of sleep yeah
okay really like have I ever spent an
entire day in bed wasting away like Beth
from Little Women yes
um bathroom I have I have but also
that's not bed rotting thank you
bedroding is you're still in your
clothes from last night smell horrible
you look like the mug shot of a woman
who just drowned her children
and it's it happens but what's not okay
is to tell yourself that it's okay like
you get up from whatever you look at
yourself in the mirror and you say
you're a piece you need to do better
than this that's the only way it's going
to be acceptable because when I look at
times in my life when I was doing that
more I wouldn't say those were times
things were going well
so it's it's it's normal but it's not
normal to accept the worst out of
yourself because you're never going to
get any better I was in a situation
where I had a a like a noticeable
indention in the mattress you know
you're not big enough for that
I mean that sweetly
yeah I'm in the same boat yeah I believe
Emily on that one
I try to share something about my past
yeah I laugh at me I don't think it
would be a dent because how would you
get out
oh upside down all right I get it I'm a
tiny man baby in a crib hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else